any shoe you need i probably have
if i don't have it i can get it in 24
hours
if you're a rapper you have a video
shoot you need the shoes coming out in
two weeks
i just have to make a call and i'll get
it for you
every day millions of people tune in to
dj college snapchat the key to more
success is to have a lot of pillows
one of my favorite dj called appearances
is this kid ben how's business in the
new year booming
i see you he's 16 years old and he's at
the helm of a burgeoning sneaker empire
one that he says has done nearly a
million dollars in business and boasts
clients like dj khaled and chris brown
are you at the studio meet the sneaker
don
so my name is benjamin kapalisnik people
call me benjamin cakes but most you guys
know me as a sneaker dog
school ends at three o'clock i get home
at like four eat dinner do some homework
then go straight to the office space and
like any good don family is important
i'm ben's
brother i'm his manager so if you need
anything call me okay not that family
i'm the mother of the sneaker don
to me he's my little boy but i also see
a businessman
he had a goal he's self-driven he's
motivated he's a hard worker
the great dons they say come from humble
beginnings
the first pair of sneakers that actually
got me in snake game i was in fifth
grade the galaxy pack came out and i got
the lebrons
i love sneakers after that probably
around sixth grade when my parents
didn't want to fund my sneaker hobby
anymore i had to figure out a way how to
get the money for it and then i realized
if i buy
five or ten pairs by paying people to
stand in line for me i could sell it to
a larger clientele and make more money
plus get my shoe for free
and then
it just finally broke through and the
money started coming in
at first it amazed me how sneakers can
go for like so much money for like one
shoe people charging a thousand i
thought it was like a joke or something
a thousand dollars
but hey
that's why he's the sneaker don
so what comes next
i'm really excited to open up a physical
store the first location's gonna be
miami and then i'm trying to do la new
york and chicago
all my friends when they dropped out of
sneak game they're like it's dead it's
over there's no more like you're not
getting under anything you're wasting
your time you're gonna lose money
none of that what was true
play themselves
indeed they did sneaker don indeed they
did